they had come to mali's Southern
District of kangaba on a rumor that they
could find gold and get rich instead
they lost their lives scattered on the
grounds what is left of the gold miners
belongings late on Friday evening they
descended a 100 M below ground in
galleries they built using wooden
planks there were hundreds of miners
hand deep in the soil searching for gold
when survivors say they heard a loud
rumbling noise moments later the gallery
collapsed silence descended on the site
only broken by panicked miners above
ground desperately calling our nearby
villagers for Help The Village Chief
nanuma Jara says they buried 73 bodies
at the cemetery the rest are still stuck
below where were the authorities when
they needed them he
asks the surviving miners seem lost for
words still in shock it could have been
them they are mostly migrants from
neighboring Sagal in Bina Faso they
watch officials survey the
site the tragedy took place on a site
that belongs to a multinational company
called African Gold group also known as
tobani resources a concession that is
legally attributed should not have
artisanal miners operating on their
site the Canadian listed company African
gold has not commented on the accident
but the multinationals paper CLI claims
it is compliant with local
legislation Mali is one of the poorest
countries in the world and yet it is the
fourth largest exporter of gold in
Africa gold mining in the S region has
become a lucrative but dangerous
business in February 2022 at least 59
people were killed in Bina Faso after
the explosion of a stockpile of dynamite
at an artisanal gold mining site mining
accidents are also regularly reported in
Guinea Sagal and Western Mali but those
responsible for these accidents are
rarely prosecuted the villagers of
kangaba are mourning unable to bury
their dead they are angry and call for
justice Nicholas Hawk Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer